This episode is brought to you by our
patrons over at Patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you’d like to join our community of Patreon
supporters, you can sign up for just $2 a month.
With that, you’ll not only be supporting these
videos, but you’ll also get access to our
patron-only Discord and you’ll get a monthly,
hour-long video of some of our uncut footage.
And if you join our $8 tier, you’ll still
get access to the Discord and the monthly
uncut videos, but you’ll also
get weekly hi-res wallpapers,
your name in the list of supporters
that we show at the end of every video,
and you’ll get our Microcosmos field guide
and our coloring book absolutely free!
So check out our patreon today
over at patreon.com/journeytomicro.
I don’t know if you can tell this
yet, but you’re looking at a killer.
Its body
is long with many threads, and it seems more like
a crack on the screen than a living organism.
Things may seem quiet and calm, but along
its body, the killer wears its victims.
It would be understandable
though if you miss that part.
Those victims have been so engulfed from
within by their enemy, they look more like
unusual leaves or bits of debris. Not an
animal, swimming around the microcosmos.
And certainly not a rotifer, caught
in the strands of a predacious fungus.
If you have been following Journey
to the Microcosmos for some time,
this might sound like a familiar story.
A few years ago, we featured
a horror story of sorts,
starring a fungus that spins a web to trap worms.
So consider this a proper slasher
movie sequel. You don’t need to
have seen the original to know what’s happening.
But we hope that, when you’re done watching
rotifers suffer untimely ends under strange
circumstances, you’ll want to go back and
watch nematodes suffer a similar fate.
Sequels are of course tricky things,
and you run the challenge of
treading a lot of the same ground.
Of course, we’ll have plenty of
violence and death, but fortunately,
this rotifer-packed sequel brings something
else to the table that the nematodes didn’t:
sex.
But first, the violence and death.
There are at least 60 species of fungi that
we know of that like to attack rotifers.
Much of what we know about these species
comes from scientists using rotifers as bait.
They take a sample of rotifers and then add a
bit of soil to see if the fungus is in there.
And then they watch.
It sounds a little dark when we phrase it that
way, but of course here we are, watching this
Zoophagus fungus that was growing inside of a
humidity chamber as it eats away at a rotifer.
From a distance, the fungus seems so dull
and uninteresting. It’s not even moving.
Except, of course, that it is. Inside the
fungus is a flurry of activity, as nutrients
and molecules stream through the cytoplasm and
across the vast expanses of this predator’s body.
This rotifer has been caught by a fungus,
flopping from side to side while
the fungus seems to do nothing.
An animal that can swim up
against an organism that can’t…
it shouldn’t be a fight.
But the rotifer is stuck, caught on
adhesive pegs that line the fungus
and make it impossible for the rotifer to escape.
And then there are the hyphae, the threads
of the fungus that grow and lie in wait.
Soon the rotifer will be more like this,
immobilized and ensnared in a cyst.
The fungus’ digestive hyphae are embedded within
the rotifer’s body and are eating it from within.
It takes only about a day for a fungus
to trap and consume its prey like this,
but it’s still not done.
Within another day, the rotifer will
essentially be filled with hyphae,
some even beginning to poke back
out through the body of its prey.
The fungus has just been feeding and feeding.
But still, it isn’t done.
Within another day, the hyphae will produce
spores, planting the seed for the fungi’s future—
all at the expense of the rotifer.
In 1954, one scientist documenting the
various fungal attacks on rotifers within
his lab noticed that they seemed
to have an unusual preference.
They seemed to only target rotifers that
have a lorica, which is like a shell.
The soft-bodied rotifers within
their samples seemed to be able
to wander all around the fungi with no problem.
That sounds wrong…right?
Shells are protective, they keep you safe
from things that are trying to eat you.
But the shells aren’t a deterrent to the fungi.
Quite the opposite, in fact.
The fungi seem to use the shell as
a place to hook their hyphae into,
using the rotifer’s shield
instead as a tool for invasion.
These fungi also go after another type of rotifer:
the bdelloid rotifers, a class of rotifers that
is fairly large, encompassing hundreds of species.
These rotifers are known
for one very specific thing:
no one has ever observed them having sex.
It’s not like they’re shy or anything.
They just don’t seem to do it…
(maybe).
There’s been some very recent
work sifting through their
genomes that suggests that maybe sexual
reproduction has shown up in their past.
But that is a discussion for another day.
For now, the fact remains that no one has
seen bdelloid rotifers actually
engaging in sexual reproduction.
Even more curiously, no one has ever seen what
is confirmed to be a male bdelloid rotifer.
There are, as far as we know,
only female bdelloid rotifers.
They reproduce through parthenogenesis,
able to make their own egg that will hatch into
a daughter who has only her mother’s genes.
Scientists have wondered about
this process for some time,
and how bdelloid rotifers have been able to
survive for millions and millions of years
without the advantages that sexual
reproduction confers on a species—
like the ability to introduce variation that
could help them adapt to the world around them,
a world that includes predatory fungi.
But that’s also led scientists to wonder
if perhaps these fungi are the reason why
bdelloid rotifers are so singularly
reliant on asexual reproduction.
Because asexual reproduction has at least
one clear advantage on sexual reproduction:
it’s faster.
You don’t have to spend time finding
a mate or expend energy with all the
various processes involved with courting
and copulating that nature has engineered.
That’s potentially useful to an animal
that finds itself on the run from a fungus.
And bdelloid rotifers have another secret weapon.
They are extremely hardy, able to turn into a
dormant tun that can survive extreme conditions.
That means, they could survive something like
a strong wind, which could blow them away from
their predators and drop them off in a new
home that is hopefully a little less fungal.
So this ability to outrun their predators and
quickly reproduce when they reach a
new, less threatening environment…
that’s a potentially powerful combination,
one that could serve to explain why bdelloid
rotifers focus on asexual reproduction
at the expense of anything else.
But it is, for now, still just one story for
why bdelloid rotifers live the way they do.
The reality is probably even more complex
than what we know now, filled with more twists
than the fungus that hunts this rotifer
and more sequels than we’ll ever know.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
The people on the screen right now, that's
right, they are our $8 patron patrons.
So thank you so much to everybody who's
ever signed up to be a patron of Journey
to the Microcosmos, especially the people
who are currently signed up right now.
You can check it out at Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro
and you can be one of the people who
are the reason why this thing can exist.
If you want to see more from
our Master of Microscopes,
James Weiss, check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.
And if you want to hit the little notification
bell, you can, but please do it softly.
We're trying to stay chill around here.